our main story tonight is income
inequality a good way to figure out
which side of it you're on is whether
you're currently paying for HBO or
stealing it lost last December
some of you laughed a little too hard at
that last December the president made it
clear that income inequality was going
to be a big priority
the combined trends of increased
inequality and decreasing mobility posed
a fundamental threat to the American
Dream our way of life and what we stand
for around the globe I believe this is
the defining challenge of our time yes
the defining challenge of our time
well one of the two defining challenges
of our time the other being candy crush
level 97 that is hard I've got a
lollipop hammer and I still can't but
the point is that the president said the
word inequality 26 times in that speech
which everyone took to mean one thing
income inequality is going to be the
thrust one of the major themes in 2016
members the Senate Democratic leadership
team that's Harry Reid on down are clear
got literally going after this income
inequality issued for Democrats it's an
all-out assault on the issue of income
inequality an all-out assault you better
watch your ass
income inequality cuz you're about to
get violently ameliorated or you would
have been if they hadn't almost
immediately backs down a new article
says President Obama appears to be
shifting strategy on tackling income
inequality the Washington Post reveals
Democrats are split on the issue leading
President Obama to shift talke away from
the subject so basically income
inequality has become just another topic
of conversation we prefer to avoid in
America like Japanese internment camps
all that time that we gave Roberto
Benigni an Academy Award you know
national tragedies equally wrong oh
there is there is a key reason why no
politician wants to talk about it and
that's because every time someone tries
to this happens this says Obama engaging
in class warfare last warfare class
warfare the politics of class warfare
trying to drive a class warfare argument
use that hashtag class warfare okay
okay that all sounds silly but the
phrase class warfare is so toxic the
president actually had to stop talking
about the thing he describes as a
fundamental threat to the American Dream
and this was so predictable that three
years ago he actually gathered a group
of historians and told them what you
could do for me is to help find a way to
discuss the issue of inequality in our
society without being accused of class
warfare to which they presumably said
yeah we can't really help you with that
although we can tell you what warren g
harding named his penis it's not what
you're thinking but but just because
politicians can't talk about income
inequality doesn't mean we shouldn't and
before we do let me just say no one is
arguing for complete perfect equality we
are not going to live in a world where
we pretend that all baldwin's are
equally talented there's Billy and
there's everyone else that's a fact
inequality is a bit like cinnamon you
definitely want to have a little of it
to spice life up a bit but too much of
it can be very dangerous and make no
mistake we are at cinnamon dangerous
levels right now the wealth gap is
getting worse a new analysis shows the
richest Americans the top 1% made nearly
20% of all the available income in
America last year
that's the widest income gap since the
roaring 20s okay
nothing ominous there then the roaring
20s were famously the party that never
ended that's what made the 30 so great
just more 20s and and the thing is
income inequality affects everyone it
can actually hinder overall growth and
just to be clear income inequality is by
no means just an American problem
globalization and technology means that
the gap is rising all over the developed
world
it's just rising faster here in fact in
the United States the income ratio
between our richest and poorest 10% is
now 16 to 1 at this point the rich are
just running up the score if our economy
was a little league game someone would
have called it by now but but what sets
America apart is that in this time we
have actively introduced policies
disproportionately benefiting the
wealthy like cutting income tax and
capital gains tax rates for the richest
in half as well as our that weird tax
rebate for orgies with fancy Eyes Wide
Shut masks the password is Fidelio you
would think you would think in a
democracy policies that benefit very few
people at the expense of very many would
not be able to succeed but they have and
I think the reason for that may lie
somewhere in America's greatest quality
optimism it's basically in how
susceptible Americans are to this we
have never been a nation of haves and
have-nots we are a nation of haves and
soon to haves of people who have made it
and people who will make it yes I mean
no no hold on that sounds great
the problem is it makes no sense
economically mathematically or even
grammatically
and yet we believe him we believe him
and there's a poll that I think explains
why a few months ago pew research
revealed that 65% of Americans believe
the wealth gap is increasing and 60%
believe our system unfairly favors the
wealthy but and here's the key 60
percent also believe that most people
who work hard enough can make it or in
other words yeah
I can clearly see this game is rigged
which is what's going to make it so
sweet when I win this thing good thing
that that optimism is one of the things
I love the most about this country I
love that you line up around the block
for TV talent shows for talents you
objectively don't have and everyone
feels bad when a person who is
inevitably and revealingly British does
this to you it sounded like two three
year olds who've got flu trying to sing
I didn't find it funny and I like to
laugh and that wasn't funny to me I
don't know what that style was it
started off like bad food poisoning
without any doubt the worst date I'd
probably ever seen you may want to be
smart and start acting like an arrogant
your mashed potatoes are behind Wow Wow
a British person just told you your
mashed potatoes were bland that has got
to hurt the reason a British person has
to do that is that we raised in a rigid
class system where we have all hope
beaten out of us and your optimism is
overwhelmingly positive except except
when it leads you to act against your
own best interests look at the federal
estate tax
that's the tax that gets paid on
inherited wealth it helps to limit the
terrible possibility of the permanent
landed gentry the idea that a house can
be passed down through the generations
until some blows the fortune on
a Canadian railway company Youth King
Laura how could you do that Lord
Grantham the family was counting on you
how could you
and yet the estate tax here is routinely
on the verge of being abolished
politicians call it the death tax and
get applause for saying things like this
my own view is we ought to kill the
death tax you paid for that farm one
student should have to pay for it again
except it's almost impossible that a
farmer would ever have to do that the
federal estate tax does not apply to
ninety nine point four percent of all
farm estates it also doesn't apply to
ninety nine point eight six percent of
anyone's estates basically if you're not
comfortable calling your accumulation of
and estate the estate tax probably
doesn't appointing and yet I
think it
a man worth a quarter of a billion
dollars gets applause for saying let's
get rid of it under current federal law
as don't have to pay taxes on the first
5.3 million that you leave them meaning
that you and your wife can leave your
kid more than 10 million dollars
tax-free and relax that is more than
enough to turn Chelsea into the world's
biggest piece of huge up see no 16
year old has a destination birthday
party the tax on estates over five
million dollars applies to almost nobody
but one reason it's constantly
threatened is that people assume that it
will one day apply to them I don't have
a five million dollar state I'd like to
someday but if I work all my life and I
pay my taxes on my income and then I die
and I want to pass on what would be
great if it were a five million dollar
estate to my kids why should I pay the
government again but you won't be paying
it you'll be gone
in fact this is the practical embodiment
of everything you want this is the
government literally taking your money
over your dead body and also awesome
let's be clear let's be clear the
existence of an estate tax has not
prevented Americans from passing on a
load of wealth of the billionaires on
the Forbes 471 inherited their fortune
and another 56 inherited at least a
portion of it that's nearly a third of
the list and our habit of handing money
down from generations generation
perpetuates another disparity perhaps
explaining why of the Forbes 400 only
0.25 percent are african-american and to
answer your question yes its Oprah Oprah
is the person you'll run to a guess good
guess
America now has a system where wealth is
essentially dispersed as a lottery of
birth and maybe the reason we seem to
accept that is that even though we know
the odds are stacked against us we all
think we're going to win the lottery
experts even appear on TV advising us
how to handle our future winnings
I think the first things
to create a plan set up a trials
probably hire a couple of security
guards do you take the lump sum payment
or the 29-year annuity payment over time
I would take the one-time cash drop
because it allows you to do a whole
bunch of things that you might want to
do in your life if you win that kind of
money you still have young children make
sure you put it in a trust oh absolutely
because it is never too early to start
protecting your imaginary lottery
winnings from crippling estate taxes you
might as well do an eight-minute segment
on how to handle being attacked by a
shark while scoring the winning
touchdown at the Super Bowl
or things to say on your third date with
Beyonce and what watch how it would be
great that would be great oh there's a
chance technically there's a chance and
watch how depressed we get for useful
practical advice would you tell people
maybe take your five dollars you're
gonna spend on the jackpot and put it
elsewhere if you can invest that money
twenty thirty years down the road that
is gonna be a much better there would be
much better odds of having a secure
retirement than hoping on the lottery
it's not nearly as fantasy though no
it's not so much more practical please
please don't mess up this financial
segment with practical advice we're
dream weavers here at News team twelve
take that over the news team five
look look the whole point is if American
wealth is a lottery we are increasingly
playing two different games in fact I'll
show you who wants to play America ball
as always we have two drawings first up
the draw for people with inherited
wealth you should all have a ticket at
home with a number between 1 and 3 on it
so let's pick 2 balls let's pick two
balls
fire it up here we go 3 the first number
is 3 let's pick another ball 1
congratulations to almost everyone at
home ok so now now the lottery for those
who were born poor ok tank hello to all
of you watching at home or through a
Best Buy window you should you should
all have a card with a number between
one and three and a half million on it
and you probably notice that a
disproportionate percentage of these
balls are black and brown ignore that
it's illustrative of nothing I can't
stress that enough it's now right tank
yeah that's right yeah now as you can
see for the third consecutive week this
machine is still broken so I can't
currently get a ball out of there for
you but let's all agree that technically
you did all have the hypothetical chance
to win so this is depressing um hey
remember how much fun we were having
over there
just one more hold up
if you get inside you just think you'll
this the one way remember when it comes
to the wealth lottery America is a
nation of winners and soon to winners